for decades upon decades conspiracy
theories have long captured the minds of
many individuals and groups across the
world the infamous ones will always
spring to mind the moment somebody so
much as speaks the phrase conspiracy
theory aloud the words alone conjure up
questions like were the moon landings
really faked did aliens really have a
hand in building the pyramids and is
there really a shadowy ancient order
called the illuminati controlling the
events of the world around us of course
the answer to all of these questions is
often a plain and resounding no now
please leave me alone but delving into
the world of conspiracy theories
collecting and connecting evidence can
be an interesting exercise in
imagination when it's all done in good
fun but there is often a dangerous side
to conspiracy theories as well and we
don't mean getting so close to the truth
that the men in black show up to your
front door and haul you away to area 51.
now it's important to remember the harm
that some conspiracy theories can do
it's an unfortunate truth that a number
of conspiracy theories especially those
more prevalent in recent years are often
used to unjustly villainize particular
religious or ethnic minorities posting
about ancient aliens can be fun when you
remember that conspiracy theories have
no actual bearing on the real world but
the line has to be drawn somewhere the
minute a theory starts to delve into
unseemly territory it's best to realize
that there's very little truth to it
there is one infamous conspiracy theory
not a vindictive or harmful one that has
stood the test of time for almost as
long as the moon landings or area 51.
who really killed president john f
kennedy
we all know or think we know what really
happened on november 22nd 1963 on that
fateful day in dallas texas but what if
that's the point we all think we know
but each of us thinks differently grab
your red string and shiniest tinfoil
hats and take a seat folks welcome to
scp-001 otherwise known by the
appropriate nickname the conspiracy now
first things first some important
information
anyone familiar with the scp foundation
will tell you that there are multiple
entities and objects referred to as
scp-001 everyone has some idea which of
these they think is the real one but
just in case you happen to be new here
we'll clarify for you the designation
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity within the
foundation's archive instead it's a
collection of various anomalies that
have been encountered and mostly
contained by the scp foundation as for
why these various files are all
collected under this shared designation
well that's a conspiracy theory all in
itself it could be that these anomalies
are some of the earliest ever contained
by the foundation and were first
encountered before they had established
the numbering system that they currently
use however could these multiple
scp-001s be an intentional misdirection
smells like another conspiracy to us
among the anomalies sharing the title of
scp-001 is the gate guardian a powerful
being believed to be an angel standing
at the entrance to the garden of eden
then there's the infamous scarlet king
another anomalous eldritch creature with
similar levels of destructive power who
is intent on one day causing the
destruction of all creation also known
as scp-001 is a database containing all
of the proof the foundation's top brass
has collected that prove their entire
universe is the fictional creation of
the scp wiki authors pretty wild stuff
and then there's this scp-001
the conspiracy itself as we mentioned
before it's connected to the
assassination of united states president
john f kennedy very closely connected at
least for a few seconds before it came
out on the other side that is because in
this instance scp-001
is the bullet that killed jfk now
history tells us that on friday november
22nd 1969 the 35th president of the
united states john fitzgerald kennedy
was riding in an open top car as part of
a presidential motorcade traveling
through dealey plaza in dallas texas a
former u.s marine named lee harvey
oswald opened fire on the president
through the window of a nearby building
tragically killing jfk but ever since
kennedy's death there have been rampart
speculation about what really happened
in dallas most theories suggest that
there was a secret organization involved
or multiple shooters in addition to lee
harvey oswald according to the
foundation through some anomalous means
the shot that killed john f kennedy was
fired by multiple unidentified
assailants acting as a part of the same
or numerous conspiracies all shooting at
the exact same moment the events
surrounding the bullet's trajectory are
designated under the code name incident
001 gamma anyone alive that has memories
linked to incident 001 gamma is part of
the last population on planet earth that
can agree on a shared concept of truth
they know what is true thanks to all
sharing an experience of either hearing
about the kennedy assassination or
witnessing it in person or on television
when scp-001 was fired it created
incident 001 gamma which was both a
pivotal moment in history and also had a
lasting effect on everything that
followed it might not be obvious how
just yet but we'll get to the
repercussions in a moment the fact that
multiple generations alive at the time
of incident zero zero one gamma have a
consistent memory of it establishes a
baseline essentially because these
people have vivid memories of the
assassination they also have a societal
memory of everything that had occurred
in human history up until that day in
1969.
the evolution of mankind the various
wars that had occurred had all been
documented and were held to be true
there was a shared collective truth
among earth's entire population up until
incident zero zero gamma occurred
however reality had shattered in some
way the moment that
scp-001 was shot towards jfk the sheer
number of conspiracy theories that
tumbled out of the kennedy assassination
weren't just rampart speculation not
only did everyone on earth now have a
memory of what happened they had their
own version of what they believed they
had remembered for example from the
moment that incident 001 gamma took
place and jfk was shot there were
already conflicting witness testimonies
from people who were actually present in
dallas and saw it all happen a
significant percentage of eyewitnesses
reported some variation of seeing a
strange unidentified figure referred to
only as badge man whoever he was even if
he was just a result of civilians being
unfamiliar with seeing secret service
agents not everyone that was present at
incident 001 gamma can agree if badge
man was even there at all the only two
people that were definitely participants
in the assassination were president
kennedy and lee harvey oswald history
diverged for everyone from that point on
remembering everything that came before
but having conflicting memories of
incident zero zero one gamma and
everything that followed it what the scp
foundation knows for a fact is that lee
harvey oswald fired three shots from his
vantage point on the sixth floor of the
texas school book depository the first
mist the second delivered a wound to the
president as well as texas governor john
connolly who was riding in the same car
as jfk the third and final shot was
scp-001
which vaporized the cranial cavity
killing him and causing incident 001
gamma from that moment on there now
existed a confusing and contradictory
number of different perspectives on the
world's history all conflicting with one
another people's perceptions began to
divert away from reality over the course
of the next decade slowly and
unnoticeably at first everyone could
still agree on what had happened since
incident 001 gamma for the most part
until september 5th 1975
the failed assassination of gerald ford
the 38th president of the united states
multiple witnesses reported seeing
different versions of the event some
even certain that president ford was in
fact killed this even resulted in
another attempt on ford's life only two
weeks later by a woman who believed the
president was already dead attempting to
make reality aligned with what she
thought to be real but it gets worse
president ford had equally been affected
by scp-001
believing that the soviet union had
withdrawn from eastern europe during the
nixon administration in reality this
didn't occur until the late 1980s
that is the true effect of scp-001
the disparity between what someone
perceives to be real and what is
actually real it can often manifest in
frustration we've all once felt that we
have the skills required when applying
for a job only to have a rejection email
sent back to us some of us believe
ourselves to be kind good-hearted people
it can't seem to find any friend that
would agree living in a huge house can
make a person feel cramped and
claustrophobic despite all the space
around them you can feel that there is
something wrong in situations like this
but you can't explain it this effect of
scp-001 can often result in conditions
like imposter syndrome where someone has
the belief that all of their
achievements and successes are nothing
more than a sham and that the best parts
of their lives are destined to fall
apart because that person does not
deserve them that feeling of not
belonging the world not aligning with
what you think is true all comes from
scp-001 the phenomenon known as the
mandela effect is also seemingly derived
from the fractalization that occurred
after incident 001 gamma the mandela
effect usually refers to a memory held
by an individual or group of individuals
that they believe to be true but
actually differs from fact for example
the effect is named after nelson mandela
who died in 2013 however countless
people distinctly remember news that
mandela had died in prison during the
80s misremembering history comes as a
result of a person's perception and
their living memory being out of sync
with that which is true often trying to
undo the effects of scp-001 can be more
harmful to a person as having their
perception vary so dramatically from
reality say you believe that all the
beatles were still alive you were
positive of it and it had always been
that way all of your life then somebody
presented you with actual historical
proof that john lennon was killed
outside his hotel in the year 1980. all
the photographs news reports and other
evidence in the world couldn't convince
you that what you thought to be true in
fact wasn't frequently this leads to
frustration and confusion that could and
often does damage relationships with
friends and family causing isolation and
disconnection of social associations if
everyone is telling you that john lennon
died but you can't believe it because it
doesn't match your own perception you
would gravitate towards people whose
alternate viewpoints overlapped with
yours this is how echo chambers form
which spread and strengthen conspiracy
theories often making them more
resilient against outside logic as well
as more extreme and pernicious so who
really did kill president john f kennedy
asked lee harvey oswald he'd say he
didn't do it and was instead being
framed ask fidel castro and he'd tell
you that he and his men were there in
dallas that day armed and on a mission
to kill kennedy themselves or there's
the umbrella man who claimed he killed
jfk with a modified umbrella but
ultimately speculating as to who killed
president kennedy is pointless every
answer is right to someone scp-000 was
the shot that changed the entire world
since incident zero zero one gamma
nobody has been able to perceive the
world in the exact same way as someone
else does if you feel confused rely on
what you know to be real what you
believe is the truth and find comfort in
the normalcy of that honestly it's all
you really have now go check out
scp-001 which is the rio 001 and
scp-001 the oroboro cycle the full epic
story explained for more on the ever
fascinating mystery that is as cp001